[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM VAMBENEPE: Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I am William
Vambenepe, and I run
product management
for Big Data services
on Google Cloud Platform.
And in this session, Igor
and Neville from Spotify
are going to describe how they
use [INAUDIBLE], how they use
dataflow to ingest and process
hundreds of thousands up
to millions of events
per second for Spotify
on Google Cloud platform.
Yesterday during the keynote,
on this stage yesterday morning,
Nick Harteau from Spotify
was here with Brian Stevens
and he explained that the main
reason why Spotify decided
to come to Google Cloud was
because of the data processing
services.
And so yesterday afternoon,
also on this stage,
Emily and Kenny from
Spotify described
how they use BigQuery, and they
illustrated the value they're
getting from the
serverless operating
model from the
performance of BigQuery.
And today in this
session, that's
another example of the
same Big Data services
that Nick referred to
at work for Spotify,
not BigQuery this time,
but Pub/Sub and dataflow,
and you're going to see how
they're being used by Spotify.
Before handing the
microphone to Igor for that,
I just want to give quick
updates on two important events
for dataflow recently.
So when I describe
dataflow to people
and how to use the Java
SDK to write pipelines that
can run in batch or stream mode,
the question I get most often
is, what about Python?
Well, good news.
Dataflow is not just
for Java anymore.
The Python SDK is now on
GitHub available for anyone
to download to run
using a local runner.
If you want to run it on
Google Cloud-- thank you.
If you run it on Google Cloud,
there's a form you can fill
and we'll give you access.
It's in early access
on Google Cloud,
obviously moving towards
general availability
as a first-class
language, just like Java.
So Java, Python--
[APPLAUSE]
And if you like Scala, there's
some good news coming as well
later in this talk, and Neville
has some good news for you.
Scala as well, all right.
Not quite as much as Python, but
there's some Scala happiness.
So that's one big thing.
The other big thing
is around open source.
So you might have
heard of Apache Beam.
Apache beam is the
result of a submission
that we've done
with many others--
Cloudera, Data Artisan,
Talon, Cask, PayPal.
Together we've joined to
contribute the dataflow
SDK to Apache as an
incubator project.
It has been accepted there
under the name Apache Beam.
And so now the SDK,
starting with the Java SDK,
the Python one will follow,
is now completely independent
from Google.
It's an Apache project.
The program that you
write in Apache Beam
can run at Google, on
Google Cloud Dataflow.
They can also run on Spark,
using the Spark runner
from Cloudera and
Paypal, can run on Flink.
And the communities
forming around Beam
to add runners, to add
languages, to add connectors,
to add libraries of function,
and we're very, very excited
to see that as well.
So a lot of the innovation
of the programming model
is now moving to Apache.
Obviously we're
very engaged there,
but it's open to everybody.
The name Cloud Data
Flow remains the name
of the Google-hosted service
where you take your Beam
pipelines and you're able to run
them on Google infrastructure
in a serverless mode, where
Google deploys and scales
everything for you and gives
you the best performance
and the best [INAUDIBLE]
for your pipelines.
But don't take my word for it.
Igor is going to describe how
he's using it in real life
and how it's working
out for Spotify.
[APPLAUSE]
IGOR MARAVIC:
Thank you, William.
So I'm really
psyched and honored
to be here at Google Next.
It was a really good
conference so far.
My name is Igor Maravic,
and I'm one of the software
engineers working at Spotify.
During the past year,
I've been a part
of the team which
has been working
on maintaining and developing
Spotify's event delivery
system.
This session is going
to have three parts.
In the first part
of the session,
I'm going to talk
about our journey
for moving our event delivery
system into the cloud.
In the second part,
my colleague Neville
will talk more about
the tooling that we've
been using to analyze the
data once it's delivered.
Finally, I will get
back on the stage
to talk more about
the learnings that we
gathered while rebuilding
our event delivery system.
Spotify have had a phenomenal
user growth in the past years.
Only in the last year, we
almost tripled our user base,
reaching 75 million
monthly active users.
With the user growth
came the data growth.
Today, we are shipping around
60 billion events every day
to our Hadoop cluster.
Oh, OK.
All the events are being passed
through our current event
delivery system, which
is based on Kafka 0.7.
All the events that
are being delivered
are being generated on
our clients as a response
to certain user actions.
So for example, when
user creates a playlist,
subscribes to a
playlist, or when
it finishes listening to a
song, an event is generated.
This event is delivered
to our Hadoop cluster.
This system worked fine
until a certain scale.
But with the load
came the outages.
Well, by observing
how the system worked,
we observed a lot
of problems with it.
Most notable problem was that
this system is way too complex.
It has way too many components
that one event delivery
system needs to have,
and on top of that,
most of those components
are having limited coverage,
and they're
operationally mature.
Other problem is that our event
delivery system is stateless.
That means that
the state is only
kept on the service
machines themselves
and on the Hadoop cluster.
If the Hadoop cluster goes
down, our event delivery
stops functioning, which
is an operational burden
for the event delivery
team, because we are not
responsible for the uptime
of the Hadoop cluster.
When you combine those
problems with the data growth
that we had, you get
a recipe for disaster.
So at this exact point here, we
figured out the system cannot
keep up with the growth.
At that point, we start
filtering the events,
and this is the
drop you can see.
Considering the shortcomings,
design shortcomings
of the system that we
observed, the only way forward
to keep up with the Spotify is a
complete rebuild of the system.
When we started thinking about
new event delivery system,
we knew that the new event
delivery system still
needs to keep the same function
as the current one, that
meaning that all the
events from the clients
still need to be delivered
to a Hadoop cluster.
To have an easier migration,
we wanted to keep the same API.
That means that all
events are still
persisted to log via
syslog, and then delivered
to Hadoop in hourly buckets.
We also wanted that our
event delivery system
have a persistent
state implemented
as a reliable persistent
queue component.
That way, if the
Hadoop goes down,
we can just keep on functioning
without any noticeable issues.
Finally, we wanted to keep the
system as simple as possible.
Simpler the system gets,
it's easier to operate it
and to scale it.
Simple as that.
We had the basics laid down,
and the only thing left to do
was to get our hands dirty.
First, we wanted
to figure out, what
should we do with the
reliable persistent queue?
Building one is
not an easy task.
Building one that needs to keep
up with the Spotify volumes
is even harder.
So we wanted to use some of
the available technologies
out there and use them as a
reliable persistent queue.
Our adventure
started with Kafka.
There were three main reasons
why we decided to experiment
with Kafka.
Kafka is a proven
technology that's
been used all around the globe.
There are many companies
being successful
at using it right now.
Kafka is an open-source
project which
has a strong community
built around it.
It is a first-class
citizen in many
of the open-source
projects we were
using today in Spotify--
Spark, Flink, Storm,
just to name a few.
Lastly, Kafka 0.8 was
designed to be used
as a reliable persistent queue.
This is a huge
improvement compared
to Kafka 0.7, which we are using
in our current event delivery
system.
So we went through the docs,
followed all the guidelines
and practices, and we
put a system in place.
It was relatively
simple and painless.
But is this how we solved
our event delivery system?
Well, unfortunately not.
As soon as we pushing production
volumes through this system,
it started breaking apart.
Mirror makers would
just drop data
if we had problems with
the destination cluster.
Mirror makers would go
in some confused state
and completely stop
mirroring the data.
We had issues with the
Kafka library, which
would go into an
unrecoverable broken state
if we would remove or
restart one of the brokers
from the cluster.
This was a lot of problems,
and at this point,
we were at the crossroads.
Should we significantly
invest in Kafka
and make it work for us, or
should we try something else?
Oops.
At the same time we were
experiencing problem
with Kafka, other
teams in Spotify
started to experiment with
Google Cloud Services.
At that time, we heard
about Cloud Pub/Sub,
which seemed like a good
alternative for Kafka.
When we went
through the docs, we
saw that Cloud Pub/Sub
can retain and deliver
data for seven days, and
that it has at least once
delivery semantics.
With these two
features, Cloud Pub/Sub
did everything we wanted.
But this was not it.
Cloud Pub/Sub is a
globally available service.
That means that messages
published in one region
can be directly consumed
from another region.
This was important
for us, because that
would mean that we could skip
flaky cross-Atlantic internet
links when publishing
from our US data centers
and consuming in EU.
Also, Cloud Pub/Sub comes
with a simple REST API.
We saw this as a big
benefit, because if we didn't
like Google-provided
library, we can easily
write our own, because HTP
is a well-known protocol.
This was not the case
with the Kafka library.
We were completely
stopped in our tracks
with the bugs we found there.
Lastly, the best thing
about Cloud Pub/Sub,
if we would use
Cloud Pub/Sub, we
would have no operational
responsibility for it.
Whoever carried
a pager with them
knows how important this is.
And after having spent
so many unslept nights
with our Kafka cluster, we
appreciate it even more.
Asterisk here stands for
that even if we would not
be operationally responsible
for Cloud Pub/Sub,
we would still be operationally
responsible for the services
that are directly
interacting with it.
Nevertheless, we were completely
hooked on-- seriously,
there was no other
alternative for us.
We just wanted to
proceed with it.
But then again,
we backed up a bit
and, well, stopped being so
excited and started thinking,
would you actually
trust your car salesman?
Was this just a sales pitch?
On top of that, at the time we
started experimenting with it,
Cloud Pub/Sub just
exited a beta,
and there was no reports
that any other company is
being successful at using it.
So if we wanted to proceed
with Cloud Pub/Sub,
only thing that we
needed to do was
to verify that Cloud Pub/Sub
is going to work for us.
So considering the
Spotify's data growth,
we were mostly
interested in seeing
how good Pub/Sub is at scaling.
At the time, we performed both
publisher and subscriber side
tests.
But to make this
presentation even
more interesting and exciting,
I decided to do the live demo.
For the demo, I'm going to push
2 million events per second
and then consume them.
This number is not
just a random number.
It is actually based on our
current event delivery volumes.
Currently, we're delivering
around 700,000 events
per second, and on top of that,
we added our growth margins
and disaster recovery margins.
For the demo, I'm going to use
GRPC, which is still in alpha,
but it looks really promising.
It is a huge
improvement compared
to the autogenerated
pub/sub client,
and it is also a performance
improvement compared
to a sync pub/sub client that
we wrote to maximize performance
over HTP and which we are
currently using in production.
Disclaimer here is that even
if I'm doing the demo here
with GRPC, we are
still not using
GRPC in production because
we are playing it safe
and we are waiting for
it to go-- to become GA.
But now it's demo time.
Can I get the demo?
Can I?
Yay, OK.
So for the demo--
for the demo, I'm
going to use 10 nodes to
push the million requests
and then 20 nodes
to consume them.
So that means that
every node is pushing
200,000 events per
second, and that we're
consuming from every node with
100,000 events per second.
The graph should show
up here, but because it
needs some warm-up time,
you can't see anything here.
But I came prepared
here, unsurprisingly,
and I started running the
demo before I went on stage.
It is exactly the same
code and is the same demo.
So you can see from 0 to 2
million without any issues.
It just scaled.
It just worked.
The same thing is on
the subscribing side.
So here we can notice it
was a bit slower to start,
but as soon as picked up, it
consumed the whole backlog
and then started consuming
with a steady pace.
These were exactly
the same results
that we observed
when we did our test.
Now you can switch to
the slides, please.
Slides, please.
Thanks.
These were exactly
the same results
that we observed when
we run our initial test.
So based on those results,
what was our verdict?
Did we went with Pub/Sub or not?
Unsurprisingly, we decided
to proceed with Cloud Pub/Sub
and to base our event
delivery on top of it.
After having putting it
through many hard labors,
we were certain that Cloud
Pub/Sub is going to deliver.
Putting it in place
was relatively simple.
We already had the event
delivery service in place
from our Kafka experiments,
and the only thing
that we needed to do is to
replace the Kafka library
with Cloud Pub/Sub one.
So in our case, you can say
that Cloud Pub/Sub was just
a drop-in replacement for Kafka.
After we had put the Cloud
Pub/Sub to a good use,
it was time to start thinking
about writing our ETL job.
For the ETL job, we decided to
experiment with Dataflow SDK.
Dataflow SDK is
a framework which
provides us a high-level API
for writing data pipelines.
It has unified bash
and stream model.
Dataflow SDK comes
with a promise
that it can be run on any
number of the runners that
are implemented.
Currently we have runners
implemented on top of Fling,
on top of Spark, and finally,
on top of Cloud dataflow.
Cloud dataflow is
a managed service.
It is able to execute the
pipelines written with Dataflow
SDK, and it comes with a
promise that it can seamlessly
scale them.
Back in the days, we decided
to use Cloud Dataflow runner
simply because we
didn't need to put
any external resources
in place before using it,
and because it was
most stable one.
When you write your data
pipeline with Dataflow SDK
and submit it to Cloud
Dataflow, you get a fancy graph.
On this graph, you can see
how your job is structured.
Our ETL job in essence
does really simple things.
It consumes data from a
single pub/sub subscription
and writes it in parallel
to both HDFS, which
stands for Hadoop
Distributed File System,
and GCS, which stands
for Google Cloud Storage.
Our requirement
is that all events
needed to be written to Hadoop.
But since we are planning
to migrate to Google Cloud,
we are in parallel
writing to cloud storage.
By doing this, we're enabling
other developers in Spotify
to start experimenting
with Dataproc
on moving their pipelines
from on-premise Hadoop
into the cloud.
All the events that
are being written
to Hadoop and cloud
storage are being
written in hourly buckets.
This is the legacy from
our first event delivery
system, which just copied hourly
log files from all the service
machines and put them in Hadoop.
This is the API that all
Spotify jobs expect today,
and that means that
we're going to have
this API for a long time.
Difference here
with our new ETL job
is that we wanted to
start incrementally
filling the data as it arrives.
By doing this, we wanted
to achieve lower latency
for delivering data.
Before the data can be consumed,
buckets, the green ones
on this slide,
need to be closed.
When they're closed, that means
there are safe to be consumed.
In dataflow, we have
a notional watermark,
which you can see as a
yellow, I don't know,
thing here that's moving, which
allows us to do that easily.
When the watermark passes
end of the hour boundary,
we mark the bucket as closed.
Once the bucket is
closed, we don't
want to backfill
any late data to it.
This is because most
of the Spotify jobs
are reading data from an
hourly bucket only once.
If we would do the backfill
in the already closed bucket,
we could consider
this data as lost.
So in our case, we
want to write late data
in a youngest
currently open bucket.
By doing this, we are
skewing the event time stamp,
but we have no data loss.
This is all really nice, but
how did we implement event
time-based hourly buckets,
incremental bucket fill,
bucket completeness,
and late data handling?
Amazingly, they mostly
ended up being implemented
in a single transformation.
In this picture, this is
a window transformation,
and what does this
transformation do,
is windowing.
Windowing is one of the most
powerful concepts of data flow,
and I have to say one of
the most magical ones.
All this stuff, bulk
of the implementation
for all the concepts
I've been talking about,
ended up being implemented
in only distance of lines.
So in distance of lines, we
define, how big is our bucket?
How do we close the window?
How do we do
incremental bucket fill?
And then let lastly, how
do we handle late data?
Skewing of the time stamp
is not happening here,
it's happening in the
transformation after,
but nevertheless, the bulk
of the job is done here.
Windowing is available both
in streaming and batch,
but only when using streaming,
the full power of windowing
is unleashed.
This is because we
have a formed watermark
which is being constantly
propagated as the data arrives.
This allows us to detect
and handle late data.
Having our ETL job being
implemented as a stream job
makes perfect sense, because
event delivery is just
a constant stream of data.
Us having our current
event delivery job
implemented as a batch job
is driven by the limitations
of the framework we were using.
The ETL job we've
been talking about
is just in a prototype phase.
We still have few
hurdles that we
need to overcome for
it to go in production.
First, we need to be
able to restart our ETL
jobs without losing
any in-flight data.
Today, this is
currently not the case
if the update does not work.
Other big thing is
that we need to have
a good continuous
integration and deployment
process for enabling the safe
and fast iterations on our ETL
job.
This is even more
important if you
consider that we would like
to have one ETL per event type
and that we are currently having
1,000 event types in Spotify.
Nevertheless, preliminary
results look promising there.
So on this graph, you can
see the end-to-end latency
from when the event was
persisted into the log file
and when it was actually
written to Hadoop.
There is multiple lines here
because we are currently
running four ETL jobs
in our experiments.
So during the biggest
spikes, the latency
goes as high as 25 minutes,
but in most of the cases
is below 10 minutes.
Biggest spikes here can
be attributed to the fact
that we are writing to
Hadoop via flaky VPN links,
and the lower spikes can
be attributed to the fact
if we are still tailing files,
which is inherently unstable.
They are not actually related
to the way we structured
and run our data flow job.
To put this in perspective,
end-to-end latency
for our current event delivery
system is around two hours.
So that would mean that
with our experiments,
we have actually four times
the latency improvements.
Delivering data is just a
first part of the process.
Once the data is delivered,
other teams in Spotify
are using that data to produce
really awesome recommendations
to our users.
Neville here is going to talk
a bit more about the tooling
that they're using to do that.
Here you go.
NEVILLE LI: All
right, thanks Igor.
So next, I'm going
to talk about Scio.
It's a Scala library
that we built on top
of Google Cloud Dataflow SDK.
So a little bit origin story.
We are big fans of
Scala at Spotify,
and I work with the music
recommendation team at Spotify.
That's that team
that built-- discover
weekly related artists and a
few other music recommendation
features.
We also use-- we've been using
Scalding for three years now,
and some teams are using
Spark as well for machine
learning use cases.
Right now, we have
about 50 users
using Scala for daily
data pipeline processing.
A lot of them have no
computer science background.
They're from business
or math backgrounds,
so not great at
programming, but they
enjoy using Scala for
the concise syntax
and the libraries.
And we have 400-plus unique
jobs at Spotify running daily.
So early 2015, about
a year and a half
ago, when we started working
on GCP, Google Cloud,
I started hacking
around dataflow
and built a prototype
Scala APR on top of that.
So compared to the
other options we have,
what are the pros and cons?
So today we have Scalding.
It is very popular.
It's open source by Twitter and
used by a bunch of other tech
companies.
It runs on Hadoop, which is
very stable, mature, and proven.
It scales to-- it has
really high scalability.
And the downside, of
course, is the operation
of the Hadoop cluster.
Today we have a
2,300-node Hadoop cluster,
and it requires a
lot of maintenance.
It doesn't handle
multi-tenancy very well,
so the Hadoop
cluster is overloaded
during weekdays but
underutilized on the weekend.
And of course, there's no
streaming mode in Hadoop.
Some of you might have
a heard of Summingbird,
which is a Twitter
library that runs
both on Scalding as batch mode
and Storm as a streaming mode.
But the downside,
of course, is you
have to maintain another
storm cluster, which adds
on additional operational cost.
So Spark is really getting
really popular these days.
It works on both batch
and streaming mode.
On top of that, it
has interactive repo,
and also supports SQL.
It has a very large library of
ML, machine learning algorithms
and graph algorithms.
It also supports Scala,
Java, Python, and even R,
so it's very popular
among data scientists.
The downside of Spark, of
course, and many people
complain it has too
many parameters, a lot
of different operational modes.
The common practice of
running Spark on cloud
is to set up one
cluster per job.
It sounds easy, but to manage
that many Spark clusters is not
an easy task, and
there isn't as much
automation or tooling for that.
So that's another consideration.
So why do we want to
use dataflow with Scala?
We already talked
about dataflow.
Cloud dataflow has
a hosted solution,
so it runs on Google
infrastructure
and there's no operational cost.
You submit your
job from a laptop.
It sends some
request to the cloud.
[INAUDIBLE] VMs does all
the scaling under the hood.
There's no operation
cost whatsoever.
It also has a tight integration
with the entire Google
ecosystem, so you
can read and write
from all these awesome data
products, like BigQuery
and Bigtable, so
that's very nice.
And the cloud dataflow
has a very simple API
that handles both streaming and
batch in the same abstract data
model, which is also
very nice, so you
can write your application
once and run in either modes.
And we also like
Scala, of course,
because it's easy to build
a very high-level DSL on top
of Java libraries.
It's very easy for
developers to pick up.
And also, Scala being a
functional programming
language, is encourages the
reusable composable patterns--
makes code easy to
troubleshoot, easy to maintain
in the long run.
We also use a lot
of Scala libraries,
like Breeze, which is a
statistical numerical library,
similar to NumPy,
and also [INAUDIBLE].
It's a Twitter library for
approximate algorithms and also
parallel processing.
So this is how it
looks like, the Scio
library on top of dataflow SDK.
So on the top layer, you
have this very same layer
of Scala API that wraps
around on the Java SDK.
We also added a
few other things,
like enabling the user to use
Scala libraries like Breeze
and Algebird.
We added interactive
repo in addition
to the batch and streaming mode.
And also we added
some extra features
that we like, for example,
reading and writing HDFX,
and also some simple
primitive for doing job
dependence and scheduling.
All right, so what
exactly is Scio?
It's pronounced
shee-oh, obviously.
Thanks to Google
Translate, it's Latin,
the kind that the pope
speaks, so very classy.
And also, it's the name
of a Scala data library
that starts with
SC, ends with IO,
so totally buzzword compliant.
So we like the name.
And the core API is actually
very similar to Spark--
I would say about
80% compatible.
And also, we borrowed
some really nice ideas
from Scalding as well, the two
libraries that we really like.
So it is open source on GitHub.
And next, of course,
this is a data library,
so I have to show the
word count example.
For those of you who have
experience with Spark,
the source code looks
almost exactly the same.
So you read a text file, spit
out lines, do some filtering,
count by value, save it
to another text file,
and that's it--
five lines of code.
Of course, this is
a Google conference,
so I have to mention page rank
as well, in 13 lines of code.
So your input is a collection
of source and destination URIs,
and the initialized page rank
to 1.0 over 10 iterations.
You distributed the page rank
to the destination pages,
and also added on top have
some dampening factor,
and that's it.
That's page ranking--
13 lines of code.
Very easy to write, very
easy to refactor and debug.
There was a few talks
on BigQuery already,
or some BigQueries.
And of course we like
BigQuery as well.
And we even want to use
BigQuery as much as possible.
We actually at Spotify have
been through a few different SQL
on Hadoop solutions.
Of course, at the very
beginning there is Hive,
and we use Hive on top
of TSV or Avro data.
And the obvious
problem with that
is that TSV or Avro, they are
all row-based storage, which
means any simple SQL
query will require
scanning through
the entire data set,
and that's super inefficient.
And also, there's no integration
with other frameworks,
so it's as easy to use SQL
inside a data pipeline,
for example.
We've also been
experimenting with Parquet,
which is a columnal storage.
It is actually
inspired by Dremel,
this Google paper which is
basically the technical basis
of BigQuery.
So Parquet gave us like 10 times
speedup over regular Avro Hive.
But there are also
some obvious problems.
The integration with Hive
is a little bit immature.
There are some rough edges.
It works really
well in Spark SQL,
but the problem is Spark
is another platform that we
have to tune, and it's
slightly harder to scale up.
Of course, we want
to use Parquet
inside the current frameworks
that we have, like Scalding,
but there are some impedance
mismatch with, for example,
Avro.
And also, the Parquet
API is Java-based
and it's a little bit clunky.
Basically, instead of
having to write SQL query,
you can select where
and all that stuff.
In Parquet, you have to
write a lot of Java code
to perform these kind of column
projection and row predicate.
All right, so we want to use
BigQuery with Scio, of course.
The idea is that BigQuery is
so performant and also scales
independently,
which means we don't
have to maintain any cluster.
So the idea is to
use BigQuery for most
of the slicing and dicing.
And of course BigQuery has a
lot of commercial tools support
and has the web UI,
so data scientists
can easily prototype, say, a
data pipeline inside BigQuery
and then import that code into
a data pipeline like Scio.
And of course there
are certain things
that's hard to do in
BigQuery or in SQL
in general, like
custom machine learning
algorithms or fancy statistical
analysis, things like that.
So in that case, we can
copy/paste the SQL query
into a data pipeline
and seamlessly
integrate with a dataflow.
And because we use
Scala and Scala
gives us macro, which
generates type safe data types,
and I'm going to
show it in a bit.
On the left side, you
have this typical pipeline
that handles BigQuery
as JSON objects.
So obviously it's a map
of streamed objects,
and you have to access
fields by string
and then cast them into
whatever you think it is.
It's a very tedious and
error-prone process.
So you can easily run
into [INAUDIBLE] errors,
and it takes a long time to
actually run the pipeline
production and troubleshoot it.
On the right-hand side, I have
a class, but no definition.
It just generates
the class schema
from the data type
inside BigQuery,
and then I can treat my
data in a type safe manner.
And in this case, if a
composite works in general.
The next is an example of
a Spotify running feature.
So this is when you
open up your phone app
and run to a certain beat, so
Spotify will recommend tracks
that you might like based on
the speed of your running.
So some SQL, right?
We have 60 million tracks,
say, 30 million active users.
For each of the 10 tempo buckets
that you might be running at,
we want to find a
certain number of tracks
that might fit your taste.
So we have a lot of features
like audio analysis, metadata,
and also collaborative filtering
feature from latent vectors.
We want to leverage all these
features to recommend tracks
to users.
Of course, as a
data scientist, I
can start prototyping
in BigQuery.
So this is a fairly
complex query.
I can play around
with the criteria
and just figure out
tracks that might look
good for running a product.
Next, I copy and paste the
feature, the SQL query,
into a data pipeline.
This is how the
pipeline looks like
from a high-level perspective.
So on the top row, I select
tracks and the features
that I'd like to use from
BigQuery inside Scala code,
do some group by
based on recording,
basically filtering out
duplicate different versions
of a track.
And it also finds tops tracks
for each artist, groups them
into tempos, then I build
a vector representation
using the locality-sensitive
hashing algorithm
to build basically an
index that is small enough
to fit in memory.
Then I can use a side
input to replicate that
to each [INAUDIBLE],
which then selects
from another table
of all the users.
So I scan through
all the users using
the locality-sensitive
hashing index
to look up related tracks
the user might like.
And then at the end.
I can store the data to
either datastore, Bigtable
for serving the
live traffic, or I
can store it to a BigQuery
table for interactive analysis.
So that's the idea.
So this is how it looks
in the dataflow console.
And one nice thing
we added on top
is the file name, and also line
number in the transformation
name.
And because it's Scala, so
each transformation is usually
a one-liner, so by just
looking at the code
and skimming through
the code, you
can easily visualize
it to a diagram here.
And you can see we have two type
BigQuery inputs, a few filter
and maps, typical functional
programming terminology.
This is the second half of
a few further MapReduce,
of course, side input, and
then save it to BigQuery.
As you can see here,
the last transform here,
save as BigQuery,
it's line number 152.
So the entire pipeline is
less than 200 lines of code,
and half of it is SQL.
So it's actually
less than 100 lines
of code for a pretty complex
machine learning product,
and that took like
two hours to write.
So it is pretty nice.
[APPLAUSE]
Of course, there
are a few catches.
This is a very new project,
so there are some rough edges,
and it's still under
heavy development.
So right now there is
no interactive mode,
although we are
working on a shield
repo, so similar to
Spark, Scio, or iPython
notebook, where you can
do interactive query
and processing.
Of course.
Google provides Data Lab,
which integrates BigQuery
with iPython or Jupiter.
So that's another alternative
for doing interactive analysis
on Google Cloud.
Right now, there
isn't enough machine
learning algorithms build for
BigQuery, but the instance
of flow, also from
Google, which is now
offered as Google Cloud ML.
So in the future, it's going
to have dataflow integration.
So potentially you can
just run your dataflow job
and integrate with
instance of flow.
Of course, the library is open
source under Apache 2 license,
so feel free to check it out.
There's even a prebuilt
binary job for the repo,
and feel free to submit pool
requests or file issues.
That's it, and next I'm going
to hand it back to Igor.
[APPLAUSE]
IGOR MARAVIC:
Thank you, Neville.
So I'm going to steal
a bit of your time
to talk about our learnings.
First, I'm really glad that
we're put both Kafka and Cloud
Pub/Sub through iterative
testing, and then at the end,
that we chose the best
product for the job.
Can I get the demo?
So this is the demo I started
earlier doing my talk.
And the nice part
about it, and this
is the part I like about
Cloud Pub/Sub-- it just works.
So as you can see, from 0
to 2 million in live demo
without any issues.
Same thing here is for
the consumption-- a slower
to start, but
nevertheless, it picked up,
and then 2 million events
steadily-- really nice.
Can I back to the slide?
Even if you're not in
production, our event delivery
system, choice of Cloud
Pub/Sub is already paying off.
It allows us to move faster
on the real-time use case.
Currently, we use Cloud Pub/Sub
as a drop-in replacement
for Kafka in few of
our storm topologies,
for doing the real-time ad
targeting with great success.
From the dataflow perspective,
I think windowing concepts might
be a bit harder to
understand, but I
think they're
worthwhile investing in.
This is because they
allow developers
to obstruct really hard problems
and focus on the business use
case directly.
All in all, I had
and I still have
a lot of fun working on
moving our event delivery
system into the cloud.
If you're interested in
learning more about this,
I would recommend you to
go on labs.spotify.com
and check out the blog posts.
There are three blog post there
describing the whole journey
that we took.
I hope you enjoyed, and I hope
you learned something new.
If you have any questions, feel
free to catch me or Neville.
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]